Ce lieu est le principal
site archéologique du pays.
Il y a un truc là-bas.
Ça doit être un renard.
Ici, chaque nuit, un groupe
de volontaires armés,
s'assure que les djihadistes de Daesh
ne viennent pas s'emparer du lieu.
Notre crainte n'est pas juste Daesh.
Il y a aussi les pilleurs
et plein d'autres menaces.
C'est notre patrimoine, notre histoire.
C'est la chose la plus précieuse
que nous possédons.
On la défendra jusqu'à
notre dernier souffle.
Ce site pour lequel
ce jeune homme est prêt à mourir,
c'est Leptis Magna.
Une ville romaine datant
du IIᵉ siècle avant Jésus-Christ.
Un joyau archéologique classé
au patrimoine mondial de l'UNESCO.
Depuis la Révolution, cette cité
n'a subi aucune dégradation.
Et cela grâce à cet homme.
Je suis né à Leptis Magna.
Cette ville, je l'aime.
C'est une partie de moi-même.
J'en suis fier.
Depuis la libération de la ville,
il y a environ 5 ans et demi,
je n'ai jamais bougé d'ici.
Ali n'est pas un militaire.
Il a 60 ans.
Il travaille dans une centrale électrique
à quelques km des ruines.
C'est lui qui a eu l'idée de fonder
cette milice de volontaires,
pour éviter que le site soit pillé.
Aujourd'hui, ils sont 70 à se relayer.
Oussama, Salah, Ali,
ce sont de vrais patriotes.
La plupart travaillent, mais ils viennent
sur leur temps libre pour protéger le site.
Comme moi !
Malgré la guerre, Leptis Magna
n'a pas fermé ses portes aux visiteurs.
Et aujourd'hui,
Ali est devenu une attraction.
- Lui, c'est un héros !
- Oui !
Il est venu ici et il a dit :
"Je vais protéger la Libye"
Tu es la mémoire vivante de Leptis.
Pourtant, quand on me voit comme ça,
on dirait un vieux fou !
Il y a 5 ans,
les Libyens rêvaient de liberté
et de démocratie.
Aujourd'hui, comme Ali, ils n'aspirent plus
qu'à la paix et à la sécurité.
Mais la Libye est toujours une poudrière
prête à exploser aux portes de l'Europe.